. I have some absolutely stunning and incredibly
disturbing video to play for you today. We've
seen examples of just about everything from
the protests of the last couple of weeks.
But today it actually pains me to bring you
this video of police in Bethel, Ohio, almost
being more part of the mob than the peacekeepers.
So I'm going to be playing some video for
you of a young man who was protesting on behalf
of the anti police brutality movement. Whether
we say this was a Black Lives Matter protester
or not doesn't really matter. This was a young
white male that you're going to see. And in
the video, this man is at one point surrounded
by right wing counter protest protesters,
I guess we would call them, who seems very
unhappy with them. And at a certain point,
you also see two police officers drift in
and they're standing right around this guy,
including one one police officer right in
front of the camera. A middle aged white man
with an American flag bandana comes up behind
this protester, winds up and punches the guy
in the back of the head right in front of
police officers. The police watch and do nothing
to the perpetrators perpetrator who violently
attacked this man. When the young man who
was assaulted by police, by the counter protester
says to the officer, I was just assaulted.
What are you going to do? The officer does
nothing. Let's look at the video. Apologies
for those just listening today. I've done
my best to describe what we are going to hear
and see. The audio doesn't tell the whole
story. So I encourage you to find the clip
online for our video audience. Let's take
a look.
Hear better.
Phil, thank you. I just got punched in the
back. Did you catch you bag? Oh, my God. Oh,
my.
This has to be dealt with this. I don't know
the identity of the two officers in question
here. I don't know the identity of the perpetrator.
But certainly with this video spreading virally
and the evidence plain as day on the video,
they should be able to be identified. So what
we need to do is actually contact the Bethel,
Ohio Police Department, the chief of police.
The all this information is public. OK. So
I'm not doxing anybody. The chief of police
is Steve Teague, whose email, which is public
is s as in Steve Teague, TVA G. UEE at Bethel
Hyphen Ohio. Sorry, Bethel hyphen o. H. Dot
gov. B e t h e l. Hyphen o h dot gov. The
phone number for the Bethel Village Police
Department is five one three seven three four
two two five six. We should be respectful,
but we should be asking. Number one, that
the attacker be identified and arrested. And
number two, that these two officers actually
be held to account for doing absolutely nothing
as a crime was committed in front of them.
They must be held accountable. There are multiple
perpetrators here. Now, more generally, what's
been going on in Bethel, Ohio, has been sick.
If you take a look at news reports from the
protests and counterprotests in Bethel, the
NTI Black Lives Matter protesters have been
hurling racial slurs at protesters, intimidating
them in one video, which I won't play today.
A female counter protester approaches a black
protester and repeatedly calls her the N-word
per w CPO. Local news. In another video, a
counter protester approaches a protester who
is white and uses anti black racial slurs
anyway and asks, Why are you even here? You
are white. So horrible stuff going on in Bethel.
We should contact the police department. We
should demand both that the perpetrator be
identified and held to account, but also the
police who did absolutely nothing. And if
you've been experiencing this type of thing,
if you've seen this where you live, let me
know on Twitter. I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
And remember that you can get The David Pakman
Show audio podcast for free every day on whatever
your favorite podcasting platform is. Be that.
Be it.
I tune Stitcher, Google Play, Spotify, wherever
you want. Get the daily audio podcast for
the long form version of the show. We'll take
a quick break. Much more is coming up today.